my name is Alex Roberts right at the
National video game arcade and I'm an
engineer here so this is Mission Control
this was my first project when I very
first started working here just before
we opened last year it's a bit of a
monstrosity
it is a game designed to show people how
games are made and give kids the
opportunity to interact with the game
and change the things in the game whilst
they're playing the game there's two
players with Nintendo 64 controllers and
it's a really simple game where you are
character and you have to get pickups
and avoid enemies and collect as many
you can get as many points as you can
and beat the other player but whilst
you're doing that people can draw
enemies over here there is a drawing
station where you can draw a picture
with a whiteboard marker let's have a
paycheck or someone move okay so we can
have an alien it's my face and then we
can scan it oh sorry scan it like that
and it's kind of there press it again
that's not in the game so when they
start the game that will be one of the
enemies that appears almost immediately
and then around here you can change all
the effects in the game so we've got
whether or not your screen is wrapping
or whether you're gonna bounce off the
sides the background turn the liquid
measure on and off you could change the
fonts in the game as well so there's
like a bunch of effects there we've got
a comic songs don't have Comic Sans
don't worry it's fine it's fine
you can change what you're going to be
picking up so one minute you're picking
up cherries and then the next minute
you're trying to collect stars or cubes
or rings and the rate at which they
spawn and you can also manually spawn
things into the game so if your friend
is near a pickup you can quickly spawn
another one so they can get that as well
also on the player you can choose from
our preset selection what your sprite is
going to look like so that way when
you're the white character can change
the color so you're the red character so
we just change the color of it and now
we can actually just go I don't want it
to look like that I'm going to pick one
of the presets it announces and
be a instead but actually I don't want
to see that I'm gonna make it say
something else so on Father's Day we had
dads was a popular one so you can change
the D and we got da then we could change
that as well so this is the Novation
Launchpad so it's a MIDI controller
these that we have rehoused behind in
our massive console stuff yeah so you
can see that that's announcers DVD as
women so now it's an alien and we can
just like change what that aliens gonna
look like and you have that for both
players so you've got three frames of
animation so you're showing kids a bit
about what animation is and kind of just
getting them to consider all of these
different things all these things have
to be thought about when you're talking
about making a game this is like a
really clear demonstration of those
things and then you can see if you start
playing the player has gone to manual
mode and now I'm in control whereas
player 2 is still being controlled by
the AI there's also some sound effects
can be changed around here so you can
change the sound volume and if we start
the game you can change what tracks
gonna play while you're playing you can
also take a photo or you can draw a
picture on a blackboard and then take
photon or become the background of the
game so it is a lot of different things
so the main technology is actually all
connected via MIDI because that's kind
of what we knew when we very first sight
now we'd make it an entirely different
way and that is eventually gonna be the
plan but like I said this was kind of
the first big project that we did when
we got here so each one of these screens
is a Raspberry Pi so that's just
displaying a webpage that is being
served from a web server which talks to
the Unity game which is the game running
in the backgrounds then each of the
stations is controlled with a TC which
is a little bit like an Arduino and then
we've got up so you've got PC running
the Unity game in the background yeah
people really enjoy playing with it but
also it's really nice
come in and they get why it's there when
people come in and go oh yeah look you
can change all the things and see how a
game is put together in that way I was
like that's what we were trying to do so
that's really nice you must immediately
get angry City made in Sheffield
it's a kind of shrunk jelly babies
fighting in a car park physics roller
game a chemical bomb low this particular
server has four Titan X graphics cards
in it
a Titan X is one of the foremost
graphics cards there are new generation